في المانيا حكم يقاد الاتحاد الكره تمثال
حجري لميسي يعود الى عهد الفراعنه روني
وتشاريتو يلتقيان في امريكا هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
في المانيا حصلت حكم السابق مانويل كريب
على تعويضا يقارب 50,000 يورو بعد اربعين
هديه ضد الاتحاد المحلي بتهمه التمييز على
اساس العمر وكان مانو قد رفع هذه القضيه
بعد ما وضع الاتحاد الالماني سن السابعه
والاربعين كحد اقصى للحكام للمشاركه في
المباريات وذكرت محكمه في فرانكفورت انه
ورغم بالقضيه لانه لن يعود للتحكيم بعد
وصوله الى سن الثامنه والاربعين
تلقى عالم المصريات الدكتور زاهي حواس عده
اسئله في المؤتمر الصحفي العالمي في
المنطقه الاثريه الصخاره حول تمثال ميسي
الذي عثر على اثارهم في مصر العالم وبعد
ان ضحك من الاسئله اكد بان هذا التمثال لا
علاقه له بقائد المنتخب الارجنتين بل هو
مجرد تشابه اسماء بين لاعب سان جيرمان
واحد وكانه الفراعنه
في لوس انجلوس وصل نجم لمباراه افريقيا
وهو يرتدي اصدارات خاصه لخميس ليفربول
بين الحين والاخر وكان جيمس قد قام بشراء
حصه الخليه من اسهم الفريق الانجليزي عام
بعد مرور ثماني سنوات اجتمع ثنائي مانشستر
يونايتد السابق وين روني وخفر هيرنانديز
في نادي لوس انجلوس تحضير الانطلاق الموسم
الكره في امريكا اللاعبات شاركا اللاعب في
خط هجوم يونايتد 4 مواسم قبل ان يرحل
النجم المكسيكي عن الفريق بعد تفضيل
المدرب الهولندي